Đóng đàn để lực Việt Nam cho biết đã thiết kể mẫu hoa đơn mới, điều trình,
bộ sung một số thông tin trên hoa đơn tiền định đi áp dụ từ ngày 1 tháng 6 năm 2020.
Cũng thế, mẫu hoa đơn mới, vôm, số định dành,
mắt số đơn vị có quan hệ với ngân xác, số hộ chiếu,
chừng hợp hết khẳng đã cung cấp thông tin trên cho đơn vị để lực khi thực hiện ký hợp đồng,
hoặc thay đổi thông tin hợp đồng, cấp nhật bộ sung thông tin,
trên hoa đơn tiền định sẽ hình thị cấp thông tin theo quy định.
Theo tập đàn để lực Việt Nam,
các hàng kým chá trong trình hợp cân cấp nhật,
điều trình các thông tin trên hoa đơn,
lên hệ với chúng tâm trong sof các hàng các tổng công ty định lực đựa được sải quyết hỗ trợ.